[Musique]
manifestation autorisée et maintenue
pour les anticadas rendez-vous 9h place
de la République à
béabre
béabre une commune de 940 âes au cœur du
Berry dans
l'Indre ici les habitants se déchirent
sur l'installation prochaine d'un centre
d'accueil pour demandeur d'asile un cada
en 9 mois c'est la 4è fois qu'il
manifeste c'estos CAD vas-y vas-y la
manifestation antiada est autorisée et
maintenue rendez l'île-de- France
concentre près de la moitié des demandes
d'asile l'État veut mieux les répartir
et souhaite que les régions prennent
leur part l'Indre département sous-doté
va créer 60 nouvelles places d'accueil
38 dans cette petite commune rurale et
ça ne fait pas vraiment l'unanimité
on va les mettre là les parquer au fond
sans rien sans jardin sans activité
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ma crainte
c'est de voir des gens qui ne pourront
rien faire de la journée faire des
bêtises justement parce qu'ils
s'ennuient dans des tout petits villages
comme ça où les gens ont l'habitude de
vivre très tranquillement et où il y a
ni transport où il y a rien à
faire je comprend que les gens se posent
des
questions depuis que le projet a été
annoncé par le ma
c'est tout le village qui s'est
crispé le maire a réussi une chose
formidable c'est de diviser en de sa
population ça a créé de de mondes
différents du coup çaéit mal préparé
initialement et voil aujourd'hui c'est
la
[Musique]
guerre un village coupé en deux
au point que le maire ne peut plus se
déplacer dans les rues sans être prise à
[Musique]
parti
bonjour dire
bonjour le monsieur qui est là je lui ai
dit bonjour il m'a dit tu oses me dire
bonjour Mo je suis pass C
hom il a posté sur les réseaux sociaux
que que l'usine là
pouvait être
brûlée l'usine c'est cette ancienne
chemiserie désaffectée c'est elle que
Laurent Laroche a revendu à
l'association Viltaïs
elle doit être transformé en cada un
centre d'accueil pour demandeur d'asile
je viens toujours là avec un peu
d'émotion parce que ma maman y a
travaillé ici il y avait 120 ouvrières
dans les années 50 60 jusqu'au début des
des années 80 ces ouvrières fabriquaient
des chemises pour la haute couture
française Pierre Cardin Christian Dior
donc là on va monter à
l'étage on arrive dans la grande pièce
qui sera aménagée pour l'étage donc
voyez dans quel état
c'est il a tout à écrire il y a tout à
écrire
ça Karine boutele en charge du projet
pour ville Taïs visite pour la première
fois les locaux donc là on sera dans la
salle de l'étage où il y aura des
chambres et des douches et des toilettes
et si ma mémoire est bonne un coin
buanderie pour qu'ils a accès voilà aux
machines à laver sècheelinge le bas sera
plus sur les activités collectives et
avec des bureaux qui
seront qui permettront la
confidentialité pour travailler
justement la les dossiers de demande
d'asile 600 m car pour accueillir 38
demandeurs d'asile entreemps ça fait un
très bel espace ou oui oui les comes
seraient aménageables oui c'est la
superficie qui nous a plu et comme je
disais tout à l'heure je suis arrivée il
y a tout à écrire c'est vrai que là bah
finalement on a quatre murs un toit et
on va pouvoir faire ce qu'on a envie de
faire allez-y allez-y mais pour
l'instant pas de travaux en vue annoncé
en février 9 mois après la vente n'est
toujours pas
signée j'ai plus de mal à m'imaginer
comment ça va être on va en fait voilà
ici on a une association de tir àarc
alors elle va être
déménagée
provisoirement
c'est particulier en effet d'être là je
suis la cible je suis la cible de de bon
nombre de gens je suis l'homme à
abattre
oui on dit mais c'est pas drôle quoi non
c'est pas drôle
[Musique]
j'y mets tout mon cœur parce que j'y
crois comment
refuser cet accueil à des enfants leurs
parents l'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
est une compétence de
l'État en acceptant de vendre ce
bâtiment à ville Thas Laurent Laroche
n'imaginait pas les
conséquences je me sens menacé vous
savez la personne qu'on vient de
rencontrer qui qui me dit
euh voilà
euh tu as pas honte de me dire bonjour
euh moi c'est je suis l'élu pour moi il
y a rien qui a changé j'ai j'ai pas
changé moi je suis comme j'étais c'était
des gens euh bah euh que je considérais
comme des gens tout à fait voilà normaux
aimables pour qui j'avais un peu
d'estime même c'est des gens voilà qui
m'avaient jamais rien fait qui
aujourd'hui sont sont dans une ce
monsieur particulièrement il est dans
une ha
Viltaïs a ouvert cikada dans la région
mais l'association n'avait jamais été
confronté à une telle
hostilité on est aussi démuni parce que
bah c'est la première fois donc on en
vient à faire des démarches qu'on avait
jamais fait jusque là c'està-dire
communiquer avec les renseignements
territoriaux aller déposer plaines et
des mains courant sur les posts
diffamatoires qui sont qui sont diffusés
sur tous les les réseaux sociaux
il est
làbas en quittant le bâtiment le voisin
qui avait invvectivé le maire nous
interpelle à notre tour vousz film qui F
le ma le ma pour ici ou un
Colab s'il est en colère c'est que sa
maison est face au CAD alors il a bien
réfléchi après 20 ans ici il a décidé de
quitter le
village je débarrasser Paris soulager
les Parisiens parce que les Parisiens
ils en ont peut-être autant marre que
nous que nous en ce moment on en a marre
on vit plus on dort plus parce que c'est
voilà moi je suis pense c'est la
sécurité je suis sûr que la sécurité
elle n'y sera pas qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
faire B en plus là ils ont pas de
terrain ils ont rien rien rien rien rien
rien maintenant il dit que ça va être
des familles moi j'ai un gros doute le
maire a géré viltaï tout seul il a rien
demandé à personne il l'a fait de son
propre chef pourquoi qu'il a pas fait un
référendum un projet cvant passer sous
silence c'est ce que reproche une partie
de la population à son maire Laurent
Laroche lui assume son
[Musique]
choix je n'ai pas commis d'erreur de
faute peut-être éventuellement
aurionss-nous dû peut-être je dis bien
peut-être aurions communiquer plutôt
c'est ce qui m'a été
reproché j'ai appelé une dizaine d'élus
qui ont des CAD dans toute la France et
qui ont fait des réunions publiques et
qui l'ont très très mal vécu et qui
m'ont déconseillé de le faire Viltaïs
n'était pas vraiment non plus favorable
à une réunion publique dès le départ et
du coup on a dit on va avancer comme ça
avec le conseil et on fera une réunion
publique après nous on l'a fait au mois
de mars une fois qu'en fait le Conseil
avait pris la décision de vendre l'usine
on va pas me reprocher ça pendant un an
un an et
demi et c'est pourtant le cas les
lettres d'insulte de menace
Sam Moncel à la
mairie c'est un dossier que j'ouvre pas
souvent parce que il me fait du
mal devant notre caméra il accepte de
replonger dans ses courriers Monsieur le
Maire chaque jour qui passe dans ce pays
nous subissons les faits divhivers les
plus atroces par les migrants nous ne
laisserons pas ce centre ouvrir dans
notre région sans réagir nous ne
laisserons pas un petit collabo
défigurer le visage de la France sans
rien faire vous êtes Pr
venu ces derniers jours les
intimidations sont montées d'un cran
trois coups de fil anonyme à son
domicile un homme lui promettait de lui
faire la peau le maire a porté plainte
pour la première fois il vit depuis sous
protection
policière aujourd'hui encore j'ai la
boule au ventre on n'est pas à l'abri de
rencontrer un
fou qui va euh je pas à me tabasser
c'est vraiment inquiétant pour moi pour
ma
famille et ce weekend là l'attention ne
va pas retomber à
béabre une cinquantaine de gendarmes se
sont déployés sur la place du
village sous une pluie battante les
anticadas
s'organisent et c'est Ludivine facio la
fille de l'épicier qui a pris la tête de
la
contestation temps et on va demander de
garder un rythme assez calme on n'est
pas obligé de courir le but c'est de
gagner un petit peu de temps et de
montrer qu'on est là on a des caméras
qui couvrent cet événement tout de même
et le mauvais temps n'a pas d'issu àc
béabret de venir défendre leur village
40 migrants belarbre c'est pour la
communauté pour la commune de belabbre
c'est
trop bien
tranquille la France c'est bien
qui
nous ah quel gros connard cel j'aime pas
il est tout se là quand
même le cortège a choisi symboliquement
de passer devant la
mairie reclu dans son bureau entouré de
son équipe municipale le maire esttendu
toujours depuis ses fenêtrre il jauge la
participation ils sont pas nombreux ils
sont pas plus nombreux
même moins je
pense largement
moins ce qui me fait le plus de mal
c'est que je vois des gens de la
famille des gens de la famille pour qui
j'ai de
l'amitié des
[Musique]
sentimentsionion
j'ir au bout il y a beaucoup de gens du
rassemblement national c'est des gens
qui des gens de babre qui se laissent
influencé par des discours politiques
nationaux ce jour-là ils sont 150 dans
les rues du
village après 9 mois de contestation la
mobilisation ne faiblit
pas super chaleureux village qu'on aime
tant au fond de nous n'est pas équipé
n'est pas prêt à recevoir un tel
parce que nous sommes déjà nous béarbre
petite commune victime des difficultés
que l'État nous impose desir médicales
manque de
structure mais c'est surtout un combat
contre l'immigration qui se joue aussi à
béabre d'ailleurs à la tribune c'est
l'avocat parisien pierre gentillet
proche du rassemblement national qui est
invité à prendre la parole je dis c'est
une affaire
civilisationnelle ce combat àre est un
combat bien s c'est aussi un combat
national regardez vos
villes regardez votre pays le
[Musique]
reconnaissez-vous alors il faut vous
battre parce que l'État vous a abandonné
l'État a abandonné le peuple français
comme le maire vous a abandonné
battez-vous des élus rassemblement
national des départs voisin venu
renforcer le mouvement on va gagner on
va gagner au niveau national quelque
chose est en train de se passer il faut
que nous élus soyons auprès des
habitants puisqu'on voit bien que l'État
et même les municipalités laisse un peu
les gens à l'abandon malgré leur leur
réclamation malgré leur refus de
l'installation de de Kada et cette
immigration massif qui ne cesse et
Ludivine facio est bien décidé à faire
plier le M
avec la mobilisation de de ses locaux et
de l'extérieur a réussi à faire plier la
décision et bien pourquoi pas oui si B
là peut être le le petit le petit KALAC
pourquoi pas oui
KALAC ce village breton dont le maire
harcelé menacé de mort a fini par
abandonner son projet de
cada loin du bruit de la
manifestation à l'autre bout du village
un petit collectif s'est réuni
eux ne sont pas descendus dans la
rue là la une la manifestation à béabre
dans la Braine est terminée ils étaient
une centaine ce matin pour dire non au
centre d'accueil des demandeurs d'asile
150 personnes selon les organisateurs
130 selon les gendarmes le préfet de
l'in Sandrine Céline Frédéric et leurs
amis ont monté un collectif favorable au
CAD C des et eux aussi aimerent bien
faire entendre leur voix Plô on crie
moins fort queeux ouais très difficile
enfin je trouve que c'est difficile
l'ambance actuelle est pas dans le c'est
pas dans le thème aujourd'hui de
défendre les demandeurs d'asile ou voir
les
réfugiés les gens qui travaillent sur
bares qui sont artisans et autres si
jamais ils annoncent qu'ils sont
proocada quel risque ils ont en fait
c'est que les gens fassent plus appel à
pour travailler forcément d'un côté ou
de l'autre ça on s'est positionné aussi
enfin on s'est jugé les regards les gens
qui disent plus bonjour effectivement ça
c'est très difficile alors au début j'ai
pris le parti de de faire comme si de
rien était en se disant bon ça va passer
avec le temps je m'en suis fatiguée donc
maintenant bah je dis bonjour ceux qui
me sourient qui me disent bonjour et
après non c'est compliqué
je toute cette haine qu'on a pu recevoir
qu'on voit
encore être favorable au CAD à beléabre
est délicat pour les habitants comme
pour le maire mais Laurent Laroche ne
désarme pas il croit toujours à son
projet il sait que le parcours sera long
et bien plus compliqué que
prévusieursieurochend c'est devenu un
combat
parce que il a été très vite mis sur le
champ politique mais certains vous
diront accepter de faire venir un cada
dans sa commune c'est déjà un choix
politique au combat politique il faut
des réponses politiques et le fait
d'aller à Argenton participer à la
semaine de l'intégration rencontrer des
autres d'élu ce sont des actes
politiques la ville voisine d'Argenton
sur
accueille elle aussi un cada elle
organise une semaine de
l'intégration la secrétaire générale de
la préfecture du département est
présente et Laurent Laroche veut en
profiter pour la
rencontrer mais c'est bien que vous
soyez vu du coup
par
comment les
disp frein à l'intégration laisse pas
seul oui bien sûr voilà ce qui est plus
compliqué en fait c'est peut-être pas
tant trouver du logement ou de l'emploi
parce qu'on est quand même sur un
département où on a 4 % de taux de
chômage donc on voit bien que les
entreprises sont demandeuses en fait de
main d'œuvre donc on peut trouver des
parcours et on peut organiser je crois
l'orientation vers l'emploi la question
qui se pose et souvent ce que nous
disent les élus ou les associations
c'est la mobilité voilà mais c'est ça la
mobilité c'est un vrai sujet et donc là
nous on est sur le point de signer avec
une association départementale famille
rurale en fait la possibilité de faire
du transport
solidaire mais le plus important pour le
maire de babre c'est de s'assurer du
soutien de
l'État c'est une politique publique qui
est portée par l'État l'État ne peut pas
faire seul et bien évidemment au
premiers chef ce sont les élus et quand
on a des élus comme Monsieur le Maire
extrêmement engagés qui croit à ce
projet et qui invit d' aller jusqu'au
bout on se doit au niveau des services
de l'état d'être à ses côtés de le
soutenir de l'accompagner voire même de
mobiliser des services au côté de
l'association pour que les Ch aille
jusqu'au bout et dans de bonnes
conditions et que Monsieur le Maire ne
se sente pas seul vous ouvrez la voix
vous ouvrez la voix bravo
voilà la voix c'est pas sans dommage
voilà il y a des dégâts collatéra on
vous accpagne mais mais je
sais au nord du département une autre
commune a ouvert la voie il y a 7 ans la
ville de
Buana 4500 habitants et un cada qui
accueille 110 demandeurs d'as
c'est iciamina vit depuis 4 mois elle a
fui son pays suite à des violences
familiales pour des raisons de sécurité
elle souhaite rester anonyme allez on va
courir 5 minutes pour faire réchauffer
le le corps ok allez yes allez on
commence 1 2 3
let's depuis quelques semaines c'est
elle qui anime le cours de danse de la
ville
lorsqueon a quitté notre pays on a cru
qu'on va vivre ici en cachette mais on
pratique notre vie tranquillement on
fait ce qu'on veut au début ils ont cru
qu'on va rester comme ça les bras
croisés mais lorsque ils ont vu qu'on
veut vivre qu'on veut s'intégrer ils ont
aimé
ça certains habitants viennent même
assister à son
cours
pass bien mais à l'époque comme à béabre
le projet n'a pas vraiment été bien
accueilli par la population au début à
buisan on entendait n'importe quoi sur
le marché c'est petit à petit je crois
que le comportement qu'ils ont eu toutes
les personnes qui venaient de droite et
de gauche il y a rien il y a pas eu de
chos à leur reprocher ils se sont un peu
intégrés et donc ça fait que c'est comme
ça aujourd'hui mais c'était pas gagné
en 7 ans 190 familles comme celle
d'Amina ont été hébergées dans ce centre
des familles qui arrivent souvent des
grandes villes des métropoles les
familles la plupart du temps quand elles
arrivent à busanais elles ont un peu ce
sentiment là on est dans une zone un peu
perdue mais quasiment toutes les
familles sont contentes après d'être ici
parce que effectivement il y a un
environnement qui est paisible il y a
l'accès à la piscine l'été il y a le
parc ililà il y a des espace vert il y a
un peu tout ce qu'il faut dansège
souhaite-elle pour autant rester vivre
dans ces villes de campagne enors Amina
vient d'obtenir l'asile elle a justement
rendez-vous avec sa référente sociale
pour préparer sa sortie du CADA d'accord
tu es quelqu'un qui s'intègre quand même
très facilement qui au niveau social
voilà c'est beaucoup partagé donner et
recevoir donc ça dans la vie tous les
jours c'est très important et j'ai pas
d'inquiétude pour toi par rapport à çaci
merci parce que j'ai trouvé je me trouve
à l'aise je me trouve très bien ici par
rapport à ton projet
professionnel là on va pouvoir faire une
demande d'inscription àemploi est-ce que
il y a des formations où je puisse faire
un
projet quelque chose équivalent à mon
travail dans mon domaine mais c'est pas
la peine d'aller dans un autre endroit
pour chercher mon mon
poste on quelqu moi Amina a trouvé sa
place elle envisage de refaire sa vie
juste à côté à
Chatou s'il y avait des moyens de
transport pour venir tard à à busancé je
quitterai jamais bus parce que je suis
tranquille mes enfants ils ont ils sont
bien il y a plein de sécurité personne
ne te te fait des problèmes rien du tout
il faudrait améliorer les choses en
terme de mobilité euh clairement euh
pour habiter en zone rurale il faut
avoir le permis et il faut avoir un
moyen de transport euh les familles
quand elles arrivent ici elles ont ont
pas forcément les moyens de financer un
permis depuis l'ouverture du CADA en
2016 trois familles ont choisi de
s'installer à busana 25 dans le
département l'histoire aurait pu
s'arrêter là mais elle sa'est aussi
jouer sur le terrain de foot d'un petit
village voisin argie soutien
soutien ils viennent du Mali de la
Gambie bien joué de la Côte d'Ivoire une
équipe bah vraiment
multi multinationale et ça tourne du feu
de
dieu le club de foot local allait fermer
faute de joueurs ce sont les réfugiés de
busançais qui ont sauvé
l'équipe ah bah sinon c'était fini pour
nous c fini pour nous à 6 on peut pas
faire une équipe de toute façon donc
vendredi on mettait la clé sous la porte
et le samedi ils sont venus nous voir
pour l'assemblée générale et on lança
club nous au départ on avait un peu peur
entre la barrière de la langue et puis
il y avait quand même 15 joueurs qui
arrivaient d'un coup bon ils auraient pu
essayer de prendre le pouvoir en fait et
ça s'est pas du tout passé comme ça il y
a eu tout de suite un
ouais ça s très bien passé nous aussi on
avait besoin deun club comme ça pour
donc c'était bien pour eux pour bien
pour nous quoi ça aide beaucoup à
s'intégrer ça te aide de sortir des
soucis beaucoup de choses en fait c'est
une manière de s'intégrer parce qu'entre
nous souvent il y a des gens qui sont
qui sont c'est timide donc entre nous
ici quand on communique à travers le
sport ça facilite déjà le
langage en 2 ans la petite équipe
multinationale a pris du galon et attiré
les regards on a des très bons joueurs
donc on est un peu l'équipe à battre en
fait le club était en train de mourir
petit à petit au niveau des supporters
plus personne venait et et pour le coup
c'est cette
curiosité cette petite le le fait qu'on
soit un peu atypique a fait venir
quelques curieux la plart se sont rend
compte que ça se passait super
bien et depuis quelques mois un
supporter de marque assiste aux
entraînements on va pouir acheter les
par j'ai trouvé les prix les prixon est
déten va
faire comment ils sont
habill originaire de Buan l'ancien
patron du PSG vient en voisin et donne
un coup de pouce au club
régulièrement c'est une très très belle
histoire c'est très agréable d'ê là je
prends beaucoup de plaisir à être là
j'ai connu à peu près tous les échelons
dans le football de gagner une Coupe
d'Europe et de me retrouver ici en 4e
division et je suis aussi heureux que
que dans d'autres histoires CIS y a plus
nationalité dans l'équipe d'arg 4e
division départementale que Real Madrid
[Musique]
donc à
béabre quelques semaines se sont
écoulées depuis la dernière
manifestation mais l'attention est loin
d'être
retombé le projet a pris beaucoup de
retard la signature de la vente avec
vilta S repoussée les travaux aussi
imaginons que la signature a lieu
courant janvier vous les travaux vous
avez une idée après derrière euh alors
après faut qu'on recontacte toutes les
entreprises puisque on l'avait on a pas
donné de planning et d'agenda les
anticad ont investi le terrain juridique
ils ont déposé des recours au permis de
construire on est toujours dans cette
espèce de pression je pense que quand
les travaux seront commencés quand la
vente sera faite je pense que c'est là
que ça va retomber quand même parce que
les gens vont se dire oui c'esti c'est
faittenant la pression permanente c'est
c'est éprouvanto si Monsieur Laroche
nous avait dit stop on arrête
effectivement on aurait on aurait
abandonné ce projet mais là c'est c'est
pas c'est pas du tout le le souhait de
de ville si j'avais voulu abandonner
j'aurais eu main occasion je ne pensais
pas que ce serait à ce point-là et et
qu'il y aurait autant de de
fracture en attendant l'ouverture du
CADA Viltaïs doit honorer son engagement
avec
l'État les 38 demandeurs d'asile seront
provisoirement accueillis dans une autre
ville du département Laurent Laroche lui
espère les recevoir à béabre à l'automne
prochain je pense que un jour un certain
nombre de béabret qui aujourd'hui sont
dans la rue m'accorderont que j'ai eu
[Musique]
raison